Simon Cowell gets hit on by an old lady
puppet on a GT plus the Pretty Little
Liars star heading to the Dancing with
the Stars ballroom eight friends happy
hump day
I hope it's treating you well last night
I was back at America's Got Talent
and it was lit literally do you guys see
this the swinging rollerskating
brother-sister duo
they brought the fire and shocked
everyone when Billy threw his sister
Emily straight off the stage it was the
first night of the semifinals I was
there and let me tell you they were just
one of the acts who really stepped up
their game but it was once again 11 year
old ventriloquist Darci Lynn who really
stole the show thanks in part to her
latest puppet an elderly woman named
Edna who was not shy about professing
her love for one Simon Cowell in fact
she was real thirsty hello Miss Edna how
you doing I'm doing great but you know
what I bet you're doing better
you got the attention of Simon Cowell
and what about the age difference you're
so old he could give you a heart attack
oh don't worry
darzee saddening those mouth-to-mouth
I was so excited to meet silence he's
just such a home
[Music]
[Applause]
what do you think your chances are with
Simon after tonight I think you blush I
was embarrassed yeah I mean look what an
8-year old puppet is singing to you on
live TV
there's not much you can say how you
feeling after tonight I'm feeling great
I feel like the audience and then is
really like my bit that I did Darcy what
would it mean to win this whole thing
I don't know that'd be crazy I can't
even imagine that and to get a win for
Mel B you're her golden buzzer I think
joseline would have stepped it up she
she's just brilliant I feel like they'll
be super proud of me and I feel like I
feel like it was worth it for her give
me the phone no doubt about that
we'll find out tonight if Darcy makes it
onto the finals only five acts will make
it through tonight on NBC but I gotta
know who do you guys have your money on
let me know in the comment section below
I've been moving on to some big news
from the Kardashian West household Kim
and Kanye are expanding their family get
ready because a source close to Kim
tells et the couple is expecting baby
number three via surrogacy you probably
know that Kim may have been in the
market for a surrogate for their newest
baby for quite some time Kim has been
fearful of the ravages of another
pregnancy on her health it was even a
plot line in Keeping Up with the
Kardashians not so long ago while their
surrogate is reportedly due in January
and our source is telling us quote they
took their time finding the right woman
to carry their baby and of course they
are being very hands-on during this
process and get this the couple is
paying their surrogate $45,000 in ten
monthly installments that is a huge
chunk of change but you know what if
that baby is anywhere as cute as the
other two north and st. we could well be
watching them start in their own eseries
until the 2040s Oh sounds like the baby
is worth every penny folks
all right meanwhile on the other side of
the Kardashian family Kourtney's baby
daddy Scott Disick was hospitalized the
LA Fire Department confirms two et they
arrived as Scott's home after a call
and for a 5150 psychiatric hold on
August 18th now for those who might not
know a 5150 hold is when someone is
hospitalized on an involuntary basis its
placed on an individual who has been
deemed to be a potential harm to
themselves or others and can last as
long as 72 hours though
Disick wasn't held that long and
responders noted the man was non violent
Disick is well known for his bad-boy
behavior but he is a father to three
young kids and if he's seriously sick we
can only hope he gets the help he needs
so get well Scott the world needs some
more Disick in the lives all right now
to the new season of Dancing with the
Stars
the cast was season 25 has been revealed
and among the celebs vying for the
mirror ball trophy is Pretty Little
Liars star Sasha Pieterse a and she
spilled all the details to our Katie
Kraus about her ballroom debut she they
asked me like it three or four years ago
and I wasn't able to do it scheduling
was a nightmare and they said that
they'd come back around and they came
back around which was so awesome and
this is the 25th season so extra
sparkles extra everything which is so
fun so I'm really glad to be a part of
this season part of the ballroom journey
are you most looking forward to I mean
my parents were dancers they were
professional dancers that's actually one
of the reasons we emigrated to America
so I think that part of it I'm really
proud to be able to be a part of that
and kind of what they started and I know
my my mom cried when I told her she's
beyond excited but I think just kind of
proving to myself that I can do
something totally different
something that I'm not used to it's
definitely not in my comfort zone
actually somewhere to the kitchen the
fact that it's live I'm losing my mind
like I'm good at memorizing lines but
memorizing dances it's gonna be a
challenge so yeah it's me fun I feel
like your fans are going to flip I think
yeah they're gonna go they're gonna love
it they're gonna go crazy actually we've
already named our team our team name is
be 18 because hello the best name that
you could have chosen like we're gonna
do this we're gonna get that mirror ball
I don't know about you guys but I think
we're in for an awesome season and
here's hoping Sasha shimmies the PLL
theme although I'm not sure it's shimmy
theme music but you guys can check out
the rest of this season's cast members
up
et online.com we're also hanging out
with them tonight on ET as always like
comment and share this video and I'm
gonna shimmy my way out of here I'll see
you guys tomorrow
goodbye